Wolf, wolf, hunt them far and
yonder.
♪♪
Bill:
The forest is brimming with
wolves.
Bill:
It's my job to hunt them down,
not yours.
But we can hunt them together.
Wolves, bears, dragons even.
(Bill and Robyn laughing)
♪♪
(Stick cracking)
Man:
She's one of them wolfwalkers.
(Ruff)
Wolfwalkers?
Robyn:
Wait!
Man:
The ones that can talk to
wolves.
Man:
With some wild magic.
♪♪
Ahh!
Mebh:
You can come out now.
We can smell ya, you stink.
♪♪
You're a...aaa wolfwalker.
Mebh:
You're a wolf when you sleep...
♪♪ (Gasp) What...
Mebh:
... a girl when you're
awake.
♪♪
-Ugh.
Robyn!
Something's happened to me.
Yea, I can see that.
Flippin great.
♪♪
Mebh:
You're a wolf now.
♪♪
Mebh:
Be a wolf.
♪♪
♪ Blood on your lies♪
♪The scars open wide♪
Robyn:
The woods are getting smaller
everyday.
♪♪
Man:
These wolves they're just
beasts.
Tonight we put an end to this.
♪With the wolves
tonight♪
♪I'm running with the wolves♪
I promised your mother I'd
keep you safe.
♪♪With the wolves tonight♪♪
I have to help her!
♪I'm running with the wolves
tonight♪
♪I'm running with the wolves♪
♪♪I'm running with the wolves
tonight♪
♪I'm running with the wolves♪
You have to leave.
No way, I'll scare them off.
(Howling)
♪I'm running with the wolves
tonight♪
♪I'm running with the wolves♪
♪I'm running with the♪